So, this is my place, the pineapple Hill grill in saloon. If you go to my page,
you can see all the work I did for outdoor dining,
for tables being seven feet apart.
And I come in today because I'm organizing a protest and I came in to get
stuff for that. And I walk into my parking lot.
And obviously mayor Garcetti has approved.
Has approved.
This, being set up for this being set up for,
for a movie company.
I'm losing everything. Everything I own is being taken away from me.
And they set up a movie company right next to my outdoor patio,
which is right over here.
And people wonder why I'm protesting and why I have had enough.
They have not given us money and they have shut us down. We can not survive.
My staff could not survive. Look at this,
tell me that this is dangerous.
But right next to me, as a slap in my face,
That's safe. This is safe. 50 feet away.
This is dangerous.
Mayor Garcetti and Gavin Newsome is responsible for every single
person that doesn't have unemployment that says not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under and we need your help.
We need somebody to do something about this.
All right, everybody I'm live.
This is Angela then of pineapple Hill saloon and Sherman. She,
she is the woman who put up that incredible video yesterday,
who I don't think you want it to become famous yesterday,
that the point of all of this, do you want to become famous?
What do you actually want to do?
I would actually love to run my restaurant to run my successful,
how that's been there since 1978 and feed my staff and take care of the
community. My restaurants will hub for the community.
The people themselves will come just to, to go.
If we can't even open now for girls,
a few for just to see us and just to commune.
And I just want to open up, I just want to open it up.
The restaurant. Yeah. And there are.
So even though you did your whole outdoor situation.
You can go to,
you can go to pH saloon or you can go to pineapple Hills swimming on Instagram.
And there are photos. I took what little money I had.
I don't have big investors. I'm a one-woman shop. And I did a patio.
I followed all the rules.
The picnic tables were more than six feet apart or seven to 10 feet apart.
Some of them we did mass. We did temperatures. We did face shields. We did, um,
gel everywhere. Uh, I did flexing all through the inside.
And as soon as I got the plexity done, they made us go outside.
I turned a parking lot into an outdoor patio on my own with help with friends,
you know? So there's no way.
And there's no science that shows
it's hurting. Anybody I myself have had. I'm not rich.
I'm not Sheila. Really. I actually have had tuberculosis and shouldn't,
shouldn't be out.
By the way, Sheila cruelly, the woman who voted was the deciding vote.
The three to two vote to shut down all the restaurants that I like who went out
to eat that very night. She makes it work. Being told now over $300,000 a year.
Yeah. She makes $25,000 a month,
a month to sit at home and stay safely
inside and eat $40 meals from [inaudible] or
wherever she did it from.
But the point is this guys I've been working with the public since day one,
because I have not had the option to be inside, not working.
And I have not gotten the virus because we were safe.
We did everything, right. We did everything they asked and they did it.
They did it in the beginning. They give you,
they give you a little project that costs you, everything you have,
and they think you won't reopen, or can't reopen,
then you find a way to open and then they change that on you.
Well, listen, you're, you're a freaking hero. You are what America is all about.
Truly. What, what can people do to help you besides, besides coming out here?
What else can we do?
What else can.
Tweet out the go fund me? I just did.
Go fund me page,
but just keep supporting us because there's so many restaurants and there's so
many owners.
I have friends that haven't even been able to open because they didn't have
food. They're losing everything. So just keep supporting, please.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.